retrouvez notre envoyé spécial à
l'assemblée nationale wassim cornette
vous êtes avec nous richard ferrand
vient de nous lire le message des
manuels macron grâce à cette procédure
du droit de messages cette droite cette
procédure a qui est rarissime et donc
qui a été utilisé par par le président
macron comment les députés réagissent
t-il
alors oui bonjour ma tâche a
effectivement vous venez de l'entendre
l'éducation vient de se terminer lui
simultanément par richard ferrand à
l'assemblée nationale les par gérard
larcher dans le sénat c'était vraiment
un discours qui était dans la lignée de
ce que de la location d'hier après-midi
et des menus de macron dans la lignée de
la rencontre avec les anciens présidents
françois hollande et nicolas sarkozy ce
matin venu dans la lignée du
mont volonté pardon de démontrer une
certaine unité non seulement derrière le
président de la république mais démontré
par a par la france en général alors je
vous lire juste quelques extraits
évidemment il salue le le courage dont
les ukrainiens font preuve la
détermination à défendre la souveraineté
il rappelle que l'europe avait tout mis
en oeuvre pour entamer ses négociations
entre eux entre partenaires européens
avec les alliés de l'otan et avec
évidemment l'ukraine et vladimir poutine
ont rappelle évidemment qu emmanuel
macron s'était rendu à moscou pour
rencontrer le président russe pour
éviter le président français parlé de
cette possibilité funeste évidemment il
note avec désolation que le pire était
arrivé il a donné des filles est
effectivement une liste de sanctions qui
te seront les plus hautes les plus
hautes autorités russes les plus hauts
dirigeants il a annoncé également un
soutien à l'ukraine aux autorités
ukrainiennes également au peuple
ukrainien 300 millions d'euros des deux
pays et aussi il a dit qu'il a redit la
nécessité pour l'europe de ce2 ce2 se
former un bloc en verre avec 7 unités et
de renouveler sur la protection de sa
souveraineté et de sa sécurité face à
cette menace russe
merci beaucoup wassim cornée en direct
de l'assemblée nationale je me retourne
vers vous roselyne febvre pourquoi avoir
utilisé cette procédure du droit de
message à l'assemblée nationale plutôt
qu'une adresse à la nation direct finale
à l'adresse à la nation c'était hier et
là c'est une façon de dire aux
parlementaires que
les tiens au courant en quelque sorte de
ce qu'il décide ce qui est quelle est la
vision qu'il a pour la politique
étrangère et en tant que président de
l'union européenne donc c'est une
manière de ne fasse pas le reproche de
solitude du pouvoir et de décider tout
seul donc de tenir au courant eh bien
les les parlementaires oui bruno daroux
il se posant en chef de l'union
européenne emmanuel macron en ce sens là
également oui alors à l'occasion sur
message concernant vraiment la situation
en europe et en ukraine d'abord sur la
responsabilité des très sévères avec la
russie puisqu'il parle d'une décision au
planifié longtemps à l'avance un pays
qui fait fi des engagements
internationaux donc là des mots assez
durs sur la responsabilité de la russie
qui est selon lui total dans le
déclenchement de cette invasion ça c'est
un point même s'il dit que la diplomatie
les efforts diplomatiques doivent se
poursuivre et puis effectivement il
termine et l'a rejoint un peu quand même
la campagne électorale même s'il n'est
pas encore candidat sur le fait que
selon lui cette crise doit aussi être
une leçon pour l'europe comme quoi
l'europe doit devenir véritablement une
puissance une puissance politique il a
dit l'europe c'est pas simplement
l'europe des consommateurs c'est un
projet politique autour de principes et
de valeurs qu'il définit comme étant la
souveraineté la liberté et le respect du
droit international
autant de de principes et de valeurs que
la russie n'a pas respecté et donc ce
faisant emmanuel macron qui va être en
campagne forcément dans quelques jours
porte à nouveau haut et fort la bannière
européenne qui est une de ces constantin
puisque dès 2017 il l'avait mise en
avant et qui le différencie évidemment
de certains de ses concurrents dont
certains pourraient être face à lui au
deuxième tour